Lamar good morning how are you today
we'll burn it down i'm awesome are you
I'm doing great what's the schedule
today I'm you know study hall we have
class that's about it so far last time
as a teacher ever asked for an autograph
um no nice hahaha and they asked for a
picture oh no not happy well after you
win the heisman then you'll probably
have teachers who are going to want to
do that how probably so have you been to
New York no chef Eric use of the first
time that does a girl and you're not
moving you're not welcome back to
syracuse after what you did to them but
you get ready to go to New York good
that'll be coming up in December but
congratulations so far on the season
your favorite moment of the season so
far individually was what ah I got a
thingy I gotta say planning a sort of
state and you know having our crowd here
give it the real down there were those
let me pay you so you uh you know you
put how many would you put up 63 against
Florida State on the man are you ever
surprised whenever you watch highlights
with everybody else on the team are you
ever surprised what you've done oh no I
just got them play football if you
needed a moment and when we talk about
it what I've seen laziness be funny me
who else uh but your teammates probably
go crazy though when they see you do
some of this stuff yeah so sorry whether
they do hoot and holler yell and scream
when you're watching the game film I'm
all sort of funny black Oh me when I was
gonna laugh you're right idol growing up
at quarterback was who Michael fit when
did you realize that you could be or try
to be something like that I see like my
senior you saw ball
and were you killing people uh ever hey
do you ever feel sorry for little kids
when you were that good um but you know
all of Amy's but I just yeah I don't
feel sorry at all no you go first are
for you so if you didn't go to
Louisville where were you going I
already know I'll always the loser no no
my mono a job oh wait a minute now you
had you had offers you had clemson
auburn here Miami yeah Nebraska but he
feels like we're not one no I got my
little girl and I'm along the way from
home really like and then I came to my
visit here and I would just pop it off
my arms or my friend here you know the
fans ideals already saw me lovin okay
but but did you show up at your press
conference to announce where you're
going with a backpack on of another
school oh yeah yeah I did little
immediately so that was Florida you are
a Florida backpack to your national
signing day hey that's mean to florida
though Lamar no I don't really take it
like that you know um I was just hair
phone no yona can do it one time saw one
tom no he's Lamar Jackson Louisville
quarterback joining a stamp Patrick show
who's tougher on you coach Petrino or
your mom oh ma haha no go see he gonna
be on you know you want to see even
great but my mom is just like ever since
I was younger she always been the same
person who she always made sure I woke
up my game I gotta see my mom well give
me an idea how tough mom was on your
growing up got a great story and we used
to be hitting in the backyard my see she
hadn't showed up a thousand government
to get better i'm sorry here yes I trust
you for her wait wait wait wait wait mom
was a linebacker no she was like a bomb
hit look she was a Nickelback look at is
that the first time you really got hit
was by your mom with shoulder pads on
yeah
uh how did you develop your game though
yeah or what do you do differently
because it looked like you could run for
you know early in your career but to be
able to pass is that the been a big
difference you know almond it never been
a problem with my own meals just me
getting the place down pat you know just
learning the system more than when I
learnt the system is just boosting our
ability to so much time well I'm looking
at the numbers here do you know what
your numbers aren't do you know how many
yards you rush for this year oh I don't
I got you just under a thousand with 16
touchdowns that that's not bad for just
being a running back in college football
and then you throw in that you thrown
for 2,000 yards and 18 touchdowns what's
more impressive what you've done running
or passing oh how this in person I want
to show off the pass first already left
so nothing right but when we got get
your football it's gonna come down soon
you were mean to North Carolina State
over the weekend you threw for 355 yards
three touchdowns yo so ran for 76 yards
and a touchdown as well if we went out
on football field and i'll let you warm
up for 10 minutes how far can you throw
it I don't know who know I have all
Lamar Lamar it's just about over wait
Huck 70 AD upon the quantum soon 75 nah
tomorrow I depart little way to go i'm
not a lot to shake good for you good for
you do you want to win the heisman I
mean I want the one heard me [ __ ] you
know if I do I'm not going to say
anything i knows it's got a lot of
season left trade and hear that do you
mom do you like surf back to win the
heisman I don't know anything you happy
some taking a metaphor coming summer
well good luck and hopefully get a
chance to be involved in the playoff
picture as well I know you got Virginia
coming up this weekend and you're ranked
number five in the country so good luck
with the individual numbers but
certainly the overall numbers as well
with the team and thanks for joining us
Lamar are you mr. Johnson soon all right
Lamar Jackson the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience